saw it they did it under a minute i  think it was uh wesley and hikaru  so uh i'm thinking that  uh just judging by the posture of hikaru  he looks like he's one foot out of the  door that's going to be  sorry i'm going to have to interrupt  it's a draw already i'm i'm putting my  house on this because you can just see  from his  from his posture he's like yep yep yep  right  off wow they must know that we're  watching and they must just want to  break from the limelight because  this exact draw as well after 15 moves  the position repeating itself three  times  this exact draw has happened dozens of  times in the melt water champions chest  store  it's just a sign that the players want  to break